[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight the holiest day of the Christian
calendar turned to tragedy yesterday as
you know in sri lanka in a series of
coordinated attacks suicide bombers
struck three catholic churches as well
as hotels in cities across the country
at least 290 people were murdered
hundreds more were wounded Sri Lankan
authorities say the attackers were
affiliated with a local terror group the
attackers were radical Muslims their
motives were religious their targets
were Christians none of that is
speculation it's true
maybe because it is so true and so
obviously true nobody an authority
wanted to say it out loud so instead
they went to great lengths to avoid
clear language quote the attacks on
tourists and Easter worshipers in Sri
Lanka are an attack on humanity tweeted
Barack Obama Hillary Clinton used the
same awkward phrase I'm praying for
everyone affected by today's horrific
attack on Easter worshippers and
travelers in Sri Lanka she wrote Easter
worshippers why don't you say Christians
nobody worships Easter there's a reason
of course euphemisms are never
accidental our leaders believe
Christians are the problem they're the
dangerous ones they can't be trusted
tell them the truth and they might go
crazy and organize a new crusade and
sheath their swords and march on
Jerusalem you never know with Christians
just tonight The Washington Post ran a
story with this headline quote Srilanka
church bombing stoke far-right anger in
West is if you'd have to be some kind of
Nazi to be upset about Church bombings
that's what they seem to think that's
why our leaders consistently ignore the
persecution of Christians around the
world when US policy contributes to that
persecution and it does they say nothing
about it for example less than 20 years
after he overthrew Saddam Hussein
three-quarters of Iraq's once thriving
Christian population is gone they've
either been murdered by Islamic
extremists Isis in some cases or they've
been driven out of the country as
refugees in Syria Christians live for
generations under the protection of the
Assad family you know I'll have to say
that anymore or even know it but it
doesn't make it any less true it is true
and you can talk to the hundreds of
thousands of Christians who fled the
country since the u.s. began supporting
the overthrow Bashar al-assad if you
want to know too
but no one in the American media ever
asks their opinion
nobody cares nor do we care that so many
of our allies in the Middle East
countries that receive billions in US
tax dollars every year repress
Christianity Afghanistan for example
receives billions from us every year why
so we can turn it into Belgium but right
now in Afghanistan converting to
Christianity carries a death sentence if
you're a Muslim the same is true in
Saudi Arabia and the UAE both countries
backed by the United States in Egypt
conversion is legally restricted and
while it doesn't carry death sentence
polls show that most of the public in
Egypt wishes it did so where's our State
Department in all this state apart which
spends a lot of time looking out for the
human rights of people in countries you
can't pronounce they ignore it when was
the last time the United States pushed
another country to treat Christians
better well in some cases would be
pretty easy to do that we could just
demand that saudi arabia or pakistan or
afghanistan countries that are dependent
on us implement full freedom of religion
before we give them anymore US aid why
wouldn't we do that
because we were being afraid of being
criticized by the nihilists at the
washington post